for you as short-lived because what you
would would you say you were a regular
oh no jumper from September okay so
about seven or six months yeah six seven
months yeah for you even though it ended
the way it ended even though there might
be bad blood now
it did change your life absolutely and
it kind of puts you in a position to
kind of explore a new career path or A
New Path of life because you've always
kind of been a personality yeah yeah but
now you can go and do caffeine and I'm
sure like not without no jumper those
things probably don't present themselves
correct and who knows the trajectory of
Life something else could have popped up
you know what I mean like but absolutely
so I'm very I'm grateful for what
happened like as far as me I've you know
no jumpers and platform that I've Loved
for years um yeah I'm grateful for my
boy disaster for presenting that
opportunity to me and making that happen
and if it wasn't for that yeah my I
wouldn't be doing what I'm doing now I
wouldn't you know my fan base tripled
since I went over there so
um it's dope yeah yeah you know but like
kind of like you said though like
certain things that were brought about
in that conversation in the moment where
he was um firing me were things that
weren't even discussed which wound up
biting him in the ass further because
there was no conversation about salaries
although yeah it was Ice
just kind of stirred up all these others
right six figures up yes but like that
was never something I discussed with
those people in the Discord and then
like Tyrell and these other people were
like yo well hold up yeah wise buddy
over here getting paid this and I'm
getting paid bad and I'm supposed to be
the star over here like it just created
his sold a lot of seeds of discontent
were you making more than everybody over
there I was one of the as the
personality I was one of the higher paid
people or was it like what you and A.D
probably yeah probably something like
that I I don't know what everyone gets
paid you were also there though I mean
to be fair while T Rail and AD were
probably the quote unquote stars of no
jumper you probably were there more yeah
yeah yeah I I was how many days a week
four or five days a week yeah but the
thing is this what happened was
due to the like when 80s was when 80
started community and t-rail started
back on fig there was no precedence that
Adam had no idea that those that was
going to take off the way there was no
president before them to be like I
should put these guys in a contract
right yeah and even like look I I
approached Adam towards the end of last
year kind of having an awareness about
that I was like yo I want to start doing
my own streaming and podcasting like I
want to offer you guys a percentage of
the revenue of whatever I do you know
what I mean because if it wasn't it
wasn't for y'all I wouldn't be in this
position and then there Adam was like
taken aback and he was like whoa I've
never even considered that but like
we'll talk about it and get back to you
instead what they wound up doing is
presenting me with the contract which
was exclusive exclusivity where they
didn't want me to do anything else
besides no jumpers yeah which apparently
is now like the president of their
setting with everybody that they're you
know well they just fired a bunch of
people yeah I mean now was all [__]
different you know I was gonna say
because I even I I was there a few weeks
ago and I feel like I just saw that
video I think you posted it it was a
crazy video I was like damn all those
people are gone yeah like there's other
people that weren't even in the video
that are gone too so is it like just
Josh now I mean they have people that
they've brought over in the past couple
months slacko's I like well actually
like I love Flacco still over there uh
Almighty suspect still over there court
and uh and um I'm uh an icon and those
are the only on on-air personalities
left hmm